thank you very much I'm rohini Pandey
I'm one of the members of the
development Community here at Yale and
so on behalf of all of us thank you for
coming we've had a great day of
discussions
so
I want to just first start because I
know these things get lost otherwise is
by thanking a number of people who
really helped make this what it is so uh
deputy director at EGC Aishwarya rathan
and she and Jillian stallman have really
um LED from the front on this so thank
you to both of
them's team uh vessel McIntyre and then
helping with a lot of the finance stuff
was Dave Cowell we had a bunch of
volunteers who as you've seen in the
rooms throughout the day so I want to
thank them as well and finally Shannon
who's really been helping us a lot on
the Elsa so thank you very much I think
none of this would have been possible
without all
[Applause]
foreign
before we get started I also wanted to
share that next year nudc will be held
at Harvard so we have a location for it
and hopefully
um the weather will be almost as good
but we'd like you to remember Yale as
the place with the best weather
[Laughter]
let me start really
um I'm going to stop for a very little
amount of time but I just wanted to
spend a couple of minutes on why we
chose to do the splenary panel on the
Lessons Learned in poverty poverty
measurement through household panel
surveys
so I think increasingly what you hear a
lot of talk about is you know the
excitement around big data and the many
ways in which
um
big data and combinations of field
experiments can be used to learn many
features of development
but in the end I think there's also a
lot of recognition that development is a
very long run process and if we both
want to learn about how these processes
evolve and how people cope for instance
with shocks and crises it's going to be
critical to have long-run data
collection Enterprises and this is
something actually when Chris when he
was here he and Mark rosenzweig very
deliberately put in place a system to
collect long-run data in Ghana and India
and we're delighted that today is an
occasion where in addition to hearing
about much of this data collection we
are also able to announce the public
release of the first three waves of the
Kana panel and so for those who uh you
were more technologically savvy than me
apparently if you scan that QR code
there you will be able to be led
directly to the dataverse site that now
has the first three waves the Ghana
panel so let me start by just briefly
introducing our speakers and I'll hand
it over to Chris udry so we're going to
start with some opening comments from
Chris udry who is the robber e and Emily
King professor of Economics at
Northwestern I really think Chris needs
no introduction but he's really been a
Pioneer I think an inspiration for many
of us and in demonstrating how you can
both
um you know collect long-term panel data
but also I think bring together many
different approaches
um to help us learn about development
trajectories after he introduces it he's
going to hand it over to his two
colleagues at Northwestern Andrei nikau
and Sam ampau Andre Nicole is a research
manager at the global poverty research
lab and he received his PhD from
Northwestern in 2017.
his interests span a wide range within
development studies with a special focus
in evaluation methodology and political
economy
he will combine his presentation with
Sam ampah who is a postdoctoral fellow
at the gprl and his research focuses on
poverty Health Care health education
digital Technologies and non-farm
Entrepreneurship he received his PhD
from Nottingham and before that his
degrees from University of Ghana
after we hear about the Ghana panel we
are going to turn to Graciela uh
terrible who's going to talk to us about
the Mexican family life survey which as
many of you may know is an extremely
impressive panel survey that has been
used in many papers Graciela is the
director of the Research Institute of
Social Development and Equity of
University of Americana in Mexico City
she holds a PhD in economics from UCLA
and then finally we'll turn to
um our own mushrik Mubarak who is the
professor of Economics at Yale and at
Som so I'm not worried about him getting
lost and getting his way here so he will
hopefully come soon and he's going to
talk to us about the Cox's Bazaar uh
panel which is a panel of refugee
migrants and so I think quite a
different uh setting and with that let
me hand it over to Chris
thank you thanks
[Applause]
it's an exciting day to have the Ghana
panel publicly released um
so there was a time that high quality
data from low and middle-income
countries was really scarce
WR Lewis and Esther bozrup could change
the way we looked at the World by having
a few tables of data from Customs
records and a few anthropology case
studies
um
this weekend makes it abundantly clear
that that's just not true anymore
there's the the the rich
[Music]
the rich data that's available from rcts
expenditure services
from administrative data from remote
sensing data
um that their their availability is
facilitating really rapid progress and
how we understand the world
in this uh setting of of Rich data
um as rohini actually started to mention
what's the use of these
um big
household panel survey data data sets
um when Mark and I started thinking
about this
um our goal was to set up a lab in which
people could
think about development in in new ways
we thought that by committing to a very
long term comprehensive and coordinated
set of studies that obtain individuals
that obtain data on individuals life
course
as they move through the process of
development and the built and natural
environments in which they're operating
we could provide tools that would lead
to unexpected insights that we'd find
things that we didn't know
um were happening
um and so that's that's what I'm hoping
these data can be used for
um can we I actually have a I have two
slides on the show
yeah I think um
blank one
okay
no you want to go back
no that's what I want okay
um so this is what panel data gets you
of it fundamentally it it gets you
what's happening to an individual over
time
um and so that's just a scatter plot of
uh
food expenditure per adult equivalent in
households in wave one and wave three of
the Ghana panel data so those are
separated by uh for a 12 years and so
there's guys in the upper left who
started off quite poor and are now doing
very well this guy's in the lower
right who were doing pretty well in wave
one and are doing badly now what's what
distinguishes them what what what's
driving this um and so that that's the
sort of fundamental thing that we know
about from panel data we can track
people over time and see what's see
what's happening
what
is unique about the data sets that we'll
be talking about uh today is the breadth
of of information that we have about
these same individuals
um so
as Sam and Andre are going to talk to
you about some of the specifics let me
just give you an example we asked people
what do you think about when you fall
asleep at night and they told us and so
here's his
here's the words that come up most for
uh people in households that have done
better over time that have gone from
that lower right that are in the upper
left of that
scatter plot they had
um and here's
here's the words that were mentioned
more by the ones who were falling um
I don't know if this means anything this
is not actually something that I'm going
to study but the the point is that by
drawing together information from
various
widely dispersed parts of people's lives
we might make unexpected connections
it's gonna come up later
um I think when we have a discussion but
so let me now turn it over to
yes Sam all right thank you Chris
so I have a task to introduce briefly
the Ghana panel and I'll do that with
Andre we have five minutes each so I
would skip or not go into so much
details we can talk about that later so
this is the outline we are using so we
will look at the sampling design and
attrition the instruments and then the
topics um covet under the Ghana panel
and then the field procedures and then
Andrea would come in with some
descriptive statistics and some
exploratory transition analysis Okay so
so the Ghana panel follows a two-stage
sampling procedure the first stage was
the selection of clusters three three
four clusters and in each of these
clusters we had 15 households selected
so that gave a total of
5010 households okay so there's a unique
feature
um I would want to highlight here which
is we track moved households and split
off household members that is Breakaway
household members
I'm sure you might be there's something
puzzling going on there why would we
have 5009
4774 and then
5669 you might be guessing so the next
slide would show us what is happening so
you find that indeed in the wave one we
had five thousand and
um nine um seven households but moving
to the wave two we find that of that um
sample
643 I tried it for various reasons it
could be the death of all the household
members uh refusal the code B migration
outside Ghana or we were just not able
to reach these households okay so that
was it and so you also find that for the
split of um household members we had 965
but we don't trace all of them we don't
follow all of them so we randomly select
some to follow okay so that is how come
we still ended up with the four thousand
774 but we were the same thing happened
but we're fortunate for the third way to
have located
396 households who were not located in
the second wave so that is how come we
have a greater than number for that
third wave so I'll move on
yeah so um the instrument we started
using um computer assisted personal
interviewing since the wave 2. the first
wave was a paper-based and for the Wave
2 we use Blaze and
um beyond that we use um service CTO for
both the wave three and then up four
okay so um here are some topics you can
find in the Ghana panel and we for the
fourth way we have introduced some new
questions which uh I mean we find
relevant in recent times so Ghana
recently introduced some um policies and
we think it best to include such
questions so an example is uh is this an
electronic transaction Levy so we wanted
to know what people thought of it and
then some feedback because this was very
controversial and then there is also the
planting for food and jobs so we ask
questions also on that and we also
include social media questions okay so
if anyone is also interested in an
internet speed data we have it in the so
um quickly the field procedure I'll just
run through it because I have just two
minutes left so like I said we have the
household tracking we did this is mainly
for the wave four we did this first we
used phones
um to trap their households to know if
they are still where they uh before we
went on to look for them so that is what
proceed I mean it starts we started with
and then we had the teams and then we
put them together and then we do these
um we follow these protocols we do a
district entry Community entry and then
an in-person tracking
once the um teams are in the communities
so I'll just skip to also once they
submit the data we go through some
quality checks we can think of high
frequency checks um we do that
um it seems like a real-time data
quality check so once they submit that
data to us we go through and then check
for our potential outliers for instance
there are times for several reasons
tiredness you can you could find age
being 3000 that doesn't really
sound right so we prompt them and then
we go through this and then we also have
the back checks where we call back the
surveyed households to ask
um same some questions for instance we
could ask the household
um we could ask for the number of plots
and just to see if it corresponds with
what the we have in the data submitted
by the field team and also we have the
high frequency I'm sorry
we had a field monitoring yeah so this
study is
um we started integrating rcts into the
Ghana panel of starting with the third
wave and this is one study which I think
created in some other cohort says
update so I am particularly interested
in this or I find it exciting because
what it does is that it shows how
livelihood support during pandemics
could lead people to adhere to um Public
Health directives and so in this case
they use the covid-19 and social
distancing okay so the question is if we
give these Monies to people are they
likely to social distance and it finds
positive effects so I'll turn over to
Andre now for him to go through thank
you
[Applause]
you can foreign
so thanks very much this has been a
great conference so far and um I'm just
gonna use the next few minutes to talk
about a few of the types of exploratory
data analysis that can be very quickly
readily easily done with gone panel data
um so we decided to take three example
variables that represent different types
of you know
um first we have the food consumption
per capita which is some across all food
types of purchased
received as gift and produced food then
we have the probability of poverty index
as a proxy for poverty which gives the
percentage probability that a household
Falls below a particular
um let's say Prosperity threshold in
this case we're using the national
poverty line and then third The Kessler
distress scale um sorry the probability
of poverty index comes from 10 questions
of um assets household size that kind of
thing The Kessler has 10 questions about
how often in the past month people have
felt
um you know depressed anxious
Etc and the idea is that it's a
non-clinical construct that's associated
with clinical constructs like anxiety
and depression
um so as you can see for food
consumption went way up between food
consumption is also adjusted for CPI I
should mention
um went way up between waves one and two
but then back down waves two and three
um similarly The Kessler went down
between waves one and two which is good
that means less distress but then back
up just a little wave three PPI went
down consistently but only a little bit
between waves two and three
um so that we could have seen from Cross
sections but um to take up some of the
themes that Chris was showing in his
craft we can also look at poverty
transitions or just more generally
development trajectories and stories of
particular households and understanding
what's associated with upward mobility
and downward Mobility so here for each
of the three variables we reduce the
sample to only households that we can
link between waves one and three
um and then we take above and below
Median on the outcome in question for
waves one same for wave three
um and because it's going to be
symmetrical here we're only showing the
um below media and wave one so this also
gives a chance that compare mobility of
these three outcomes as food consumption
you can see there's a good amount of
Mobility
PPI not so much 79 of the households who
were below median in wave one stayed
below median and wave three
um and then Kessler also more Mobility
so of course we can't say for sure
what's measurement error and what's
actually capturing things PPI should be
more precise but also
um because of the the types of questions
asked but also since it involves durable
assets there's likely something real
going on
um so now to break this out just one
more step one of the biggest uh social
distinctions we could say in Ghana is
north versus South social and
geographical and agroecological um so
there's a lot of people going on here
and so we want to see his Mobility
higher for Northern or for southern
Etc so
um so now starting with food consumption
um we can see that in the South below
median there's a good amount of Mobility
a lot of people and who are below median
and South and wave one we're above
median by wave three
um but the situation was not so great
for below median households in the north
they were overwhelmingly still below
median uh by wave three 12 years later
and then a similar story for above and
below now we're not controlling for
regional price differences so that could
be part of this but as we'll see the
pattern's the same for PPI for below
median and not so much or above median
so this is a much Starker table as you
can see especially point you towards the
second row where 96 of the households
who are below median and the PPI index
in wave one stayed below median and
waived three and so then um
psychological distress on the other hand
there's a lot more movement and so of
course we're thinking not only about the
actual Trends but about how these
different variables are capturing
different constructs that might vary
more quickly in real life and we're
thinking about potential threats to um
you know a measurement error and other
validity concerns um so these are some
density plots like Chris showed and you
can see on the left we have this South
most of the households are above the
line meaning that they had experienced
upward mobility and it's the opposite
for the South so I'll actually wrap up
there there's some other interesting
findings with farms and plots but
um yeah so we very much hope that you
all use the data and share the results
with us
um and maybe even present them next year
at any UDC so thank you very much
[Applause]
becoming
well um thank you very much for the
mutation uh to be here I'm going to be
talking about poverty measurement in
Mexico and specifically using the
Mexican family live service
so
um one second
how do I do it the green one yeah oh
there it is okay
all right so
um poverty measurement in Mexico
official is done by Carnival the Mexican
Council for the evaluation of social
policy and they have a mandate it has to
be done every two years
uh at the at the national level and at
the state level and they have to use
official data coming from the National
Bureau of Statistics and the indicators
have to be decomposable
and it has uh the the national Europe
statistics produces the income
expenditure survey which is a series of
cross-sections so what we use is
actually that information to produce the
official uh measurement so this is uh
basically the methodology that we use so
we have on the x-axis social deprivation
which goes from the right to the left if
you have one two three four five six
social deprivations and on the uh y-axis
you have basically income economic
well-being so the interaction between
these two Dimensions is what gives you
poverty so extreme poverty is the red
box and it's it basically is three
deprivations or more and below a minimum
income level and it's basically ten
percent of the population
uh across all years in the last 10 years
is basically the same
uh and then we have uh moderate poverty
which is if you have at least one
deprivation and you're below this uh
upper income level so you're moderately
poor and it's basically 36 percent of
the population in that quadrant and then
uh the rest of the country is divided
into non-poor which is the green uh
quadrant which is basically 19 and then
you have the vulnerable by income which
is like five percent of the population
which is those below the income poverty
line but no social deprivation or the
vulnerable by uh social deprivations
which are those that have high a high
income but have some sort of uh
deprivation so basically if you look at
poverty measurements in Mexico the
indicators they don't typically change
across time and
um so the question is
um we don't know anything about poverty
transition so we see 10 10 percent of
people being in extreme poverty and the
question is whether there's actually no
Mobility out of poverty are people
living in extreme poverty able to ever
get out of poverty or not
so we're going to use the mxfls which is
this longitudinal study
to try to answer and look at some of
these questions so uh if a person is
born poor will share or or he died being
poor is there social Mobility as
measured by these changes in poverty
status
and is their way out of poverty so I'm
going to present some of the exercises
that we did to try to answer uh this
question so we're going to use the
Mexican family life survey which is the
only uh nationally representative panel
multi-topic purpose survey in Mexico
and it allows to study associations
between different indicators of welfare
because it has everything you can think
of I'm sure it has so you can go into
the web I'm not I don't have a lot of
time to to go into a lot of details but
it collects biomarkers objective and
subjective indicators of health
interviews everyone in the in the
household as opposed to the
representative respondent and it also
collects information about the community
crisis and infrastructure at the local
level it's a longitudinal survey as I
said it relocates every interviews
Baseline at the Baseline sample
collected in 2002 and it tracks
individuals both within Mexico and into
the United States so there's three ways
we actually feel that started Fielding a
fourth wave in
in in
2018
but we the
it's really painful to say this but the
government actually cut funding and we
couldn't even finish the the fourth wave
so it's basically like half done
uh approximately we started collecting
35 000 individuals in the Baseline and
we're about for the 40 000 respondents
uh by the last week so uh I'm not going
to talk about this because I don't have
a lot of uh time the only thing that I'm
going to say is that why Ireland
internal data useful for the study of
measurement so as Chris was saying is
obviously to track individuals across
time and to see look at transitions in
and out of poverty that's one advantage
and another one is that since it's the
same households across time you can use
information from different ways to
complement and to uh to to complement
the study of of property measurements so
for example we use
expenditures as opposed to income
because we followed these people uh
along the years and we we thought and we
proved that it was better to use
Furniture when using poverty
measurements but also for example we
didn't have information about food
deprivation in all the ways only in the
third wave so we use that information to
model food deprivation in the first two
waves so that's one of the advantages so
I'm not going to stop on this so what
are the social deprivation success to
Education Health social security housing
basic basic services and food
so we're going to use these
definition of poverty in Mexico
and uh well I'm just going to show you I
ca I don't I cannot really stop here but
if you use mxfl sub cross section and
compare to what indicators are obtained
using the carnival the efficient
measures uh the numbers are basically
very similar
so
um we're going to use for this exercise
that I'm going to show you we're going
to classify poverty into four groups the
first is uh chronic poverty so those are
that in the three ways we're always
classified as poor then we have the
persistent poverty so comprised of
people who experience poverty in two of
the three waves
and transitory poverty those who were
classified as four in one and then none
poor never classified as poor
so so we basically have all these kinds
of combinations across the three waves
and so what are the results that we get
so this is uh
how is how is it distributed among these
four groups so it's basically 25
almost equally distributed between the
four groups
and another way of reading it is that 75
of the population in Mexico in this La
this 10 years of the study period have
imported at least once so this is a
different way of interpreting these
results and if you look at for example
uh the extreme poverty which is the the
lowest one extreme chronic poverty is
less than two percent in Mexico extreme
persistent poverty five percent
transitory 16 so another way of putting
it is that one out of every five people
in Mexico have been in extreme poverty
in this last uh in this study period of
10 years
so
um
so people if if you look at for example
at the official poverty measurements in
um in Mexico those are those official
indicators are used to delineate or
design public policies so public
policies based on those first graphs
that I show you or those first
statistics guide you to very different
policies as if you used this uh
longitudinal or panel uh results so the
the
that conclusions would be different
so
um public policy is currently designed
by using these static groups so policies
aimed at helping these groups may be
focused only on short-term policy
poverty alleviation and not looking at
the structural causes of poverty so
that's something that can be done I'm
not going to stop at this I will share
my slides later with you guys so you can
see
um what the data looks like in terms of
the chronicity of poverty but
determinants of current poverty differ
significantly from determinants of
transitory poverty
um sorry and they're very deep they're
very different depending obviously on
the income poverty line that you use
poverty in general is associated with
the number of adults in the households
because those are the ones working and
those are the ones that are generating
income
but uh specifically chronicity of
poverty is very much associated with
schooling and health conditions so more
schooling and Better Health leads to
lower chronicity of uh poverty as one
would expect so uh employment and
particularly program employment are the
corner store for permanent poverty
reduction let me just go to the last
slide which talks about the lessons
learned
and I would say that longitudinal
approaches give more information and
information that is more suited in order
to delineate or design a protective
public policies this multi-purpose
component also asks a lot because you
can use a lot of a breadth of of social
demographic indicators to uh to design
these anti-poverty
projects and typically and this is
something that I will just be my my last
comment that I think is something very
nice for you guys working on these
topics is that a lot of our countries
especially in Latin America are
suffering are suffering from our
democracies are suffering and are we're
shaking and also the data collection is
shaking in our countries and there's
some countries in Latin America that are
not being able to collect data to study
poverty or to study any any anything
else so it's it's a very good idea for
efforts uh
that efforts can be done from the
academic academic point of view to
collect this kind of data so that we can
produce poverty estimates and we can
compare poverty estimates over time so
I'll stop here thank you
[Applause]
um
so um I mean given the excellent
presentations we've heard from uh Ghana
and Mexico I'll do something different
first of all I won't have slides uh but
I'll try to focus on how the specific
activity that we have in southern
Bangladesh and talks with our district
um is is different but also how it
connects to uh other efforts and um but
first before getting getting into it
um I I when rohini ashwaria the
leadership team here asked me to do this
I thought it was a fantastic idea to
have a plenary session that highlights
like data public goods right because
often in these conferences we have like
some special talk that's elevated
whereas I feel like this is exactly the
type of conversation we should be having
and hopefully this incentivizes people
to also contribute to various data
public goods
um but but I should say more broadly uh
rohini Aishwarya Nick best of Jillian
everybody fantastic professionally
organizer managed conference thank you
so much from all of us
um okay so this the Cox Bazar panel
service cbps it's um it's focused on a
very unusual and very specific
population uh the rohingya refugees we
had a large influx of rohingya refugees
from Myanmar into Bangladesh in 2017
there were a lot of rohingyas before
that and actually we started a a data
collection process with them even prior
to 2017 and then suddenly in the middle
of preparing you know we had close to a
million people who showed up in the
matter of a couple of months in a
country that wasn't very very well
prepared to handle such a large influx
um and and so and at that point uh to
Yale leadership credit everybody was
thinking about okay how do we contribute
and that's we we decided that maybe we
should start asking some questions and
collecting some information that might
be useful for policy right and so that
led to identifying you know we need to
understand uh what's happening with this
particular population right that's
important because I mean there was going
to be a case in the international court
of justice this right and it was
important that their voices be heard
because aung San tsuchi was presenting
the Myanmar voice right and so we needed
systematic data and then the myanmar's
uh commentary always was oh these uh
like journalistic accounts they're not
representative Etc so we wanted to get
some representative information about
the trauma that the rohingya had had
experienced but it was also clear to me
as soon as I started visiting the area
that what happens in five years or ten
years to this population initially in
2017 everybody was just focused on how
do we provide the most basic Services
just food and shelter sanitation water
Etc right everybody was just focused on
that as they should have been that's
that's what was needed immediately but
but it was also clear to me that five or
ten years what happens to this
population over time will depend on how
local politics changes right so the
Bangladesh government made our prime
minister made a very brave decision at
that point
um that yeah of course we're going to
welcome them we were refugees once which
is true only 50 years ago and and so
it's our responsibility to make room but
as soon as people start getting
impatient with their presence because
the people who live in the area they
themselves are deprived and poor right
so if they start getting impatient and
the politics changes that creates a much
more dangerous situation right so
therefore we decided to do the survey
not only of the rohingya but what we
call the host community so people who
are already living there
um and then there's a third population
of pre-2017 rohingya Rivals who are
trying to they were it was illegal for
them to be there but they were trying to
come then blend into the population but
also to have a contrast not only the
host community that was immediately
surrounding the camps but host
communities that were farther away from
the camps just to have that contrast as
well
um
and
um so now let me let me now get into the
details of the data itself so so we
decided to in order to create a sampling
frame and then have a sample of 5 000
people that we would follow around in a
panel right we first had to have touch
points like uh kind of a sampling or uh
or like a census type exercise so we had
to have touch points with about 55 000
people or households so what we ended up
doing was okay so from those 55 000
we'll choose these five thousand to
um to survey intensively over time
and the other 50 000 was we we just made
it available to researchers saying look
if you here's a sampling frame we've
already done that exercise like
something that might be uh costly right
uh and we would welcome anybody who has
ideas on let's say they want to run
interventions that might be beneficial
to this population whether it's cash
transfers or psychosocial work etc so
researchers can come in and use that
sampling frame and if you want to do
intervention-based experimental research
you're allowed to do that right and and
it's just the 5 000 households that we
wouldn't want to start running
interventions in that sample because
then they would cease to be
representative right and that would
undermine so so we we created these two
subpopulations 50 000 of people who we
could run interventions on versus not
right and the data are all publicly
available I hope people choose to use it
we are now we did one round of intensive
sort of in-person surveying and then we
did multiple during covet we did
multiple rounds of phone surveys to
continue also maintaining touch points
so that we could more easily track them
as you can imagine this is a population
that's going to be very difficult for us
to track over time precisely because
they're mobile and they don't want to be
there they'd like to get out as soon as
they can and in fact the government
relocated a lot of them in a politically
contentious decision to uh chart area
like a island type area
um and
um
okay and then the other uh the the other
benefit of um you know having these two
subpopulations is that if you end up
running interventions in like the some
you know in some sub sample of the 50
000 people then the nice thing is that
you have 5 000 uh our sample households
the panel households who you could uh
who you could use at the very very large
control group right so then if you run
experiments on you know you choose 200
people or 500 people to run an
experiment on somewhere else you have
you automatically as long as we maintain
um uh measurement consistency in
measurement then you could use uh you
could use that so again everyone's
welcome to um uh to to come and uh and
do research here
um
so uh yeah one other thing one other
point I'll mention about the importance
of the of a panel so there was an
unintended benefit during the covet
period which is that I learned that um
like during covet suddenly of course we
had to all everybody had to stop our
in-person data collection activities but
thankfully we had along with this sample
and other areas in Bangladesh we had a
sample of people whose statistical
properties we had some understanding of
so we knew what adjustments we'd have to
make plus
um we had their phone numbers and we
also knew that the phones were picked up
only three four months before right and
so that allowed us to quickly in March
2020 itself start doing High frequent
um high frequency data collection uh for
these populations and and so that so for
example actually across the Ghana survey
and other countries and the Bangladesh
surveys we ended up writing a paper so
even though Chris and I were colleagues
for a decade we never managed to write a
paper together he left and during the
covet period we did right uh dude thanks
thanks to all this data
um and uh okay so one you know uh so one
like sort of tangible example of how the
panel uh uh panel Dimension helps now it
turns out there's a lot of seasonality
right which is not a surprise to any any
development Economist like within within
year there's a lot of variation in
people's outcomes and so kobit just
kovit just happened to hit in some
countries that happened to hit during a
good period like a harvest period where
people had grain stocks in other
countries they were the pre-harvest
period right and so we were learning
thankfully once you have the a lot of
the pre-coveted data right you could
track you know as long as it was high
frequency enough you could track what
kind of seasonal variation there was and
that allowed us to say that look in this
country maybe people aren't suffering so
much right now right but that's not good
news because relative to the same season
in the previous year it was actually
really bad news right this is why also I
think when we all contribute to these
kind of data public goods they sometimes
pay off dividends for for us in
unanticipated ways
and the final thing I'll mention is
about Partnerships so even though Yale
was willing to for the first round was
willing to pay for the survey themselves
we ended up partnering with the World
Bank and unhcr
and that's been very useful because
those two organizations and other than
funds and money they also have really
good convening power right which is
really valuable so for example the way
our unhcr partnership works right now we
figured out that they're not
particularly useful in terms of like
statistical decision sampling frames Etc
but the the unhcr country representative
is very very useful in telling us sort
of keeping the pulse of like what is it
that we need to know in the next round
right so essentially the partnership we
have is that they tell us okay here are
the policy questions that need to be
answered so that our research team can
be responsive exactly to that and here I
should um I'm here on stage talking but
the the person who's over time taken on
the lead Pi role Paola Lopez Pena she's
a Queen's University and she has been
maintaining a lot of those
thank you thanks very much
[Applause]
so we are a bit short of time but we
wanted to take a couple of questions uh
from the audience but let me start by
abusing my privilege as moderator to ask
a question
um to the panelists and any subset of
them can answer which is we've heard a
lot about these fantastic data sets and
as mushrik highlighted it's really an
amazing public good that's been provided
to us but when I put on my hat of
thinking about when I'm talking to our
students at a young researchers we
always emphasize that you know don't
start with the data set start with the
question so I was curious how you would
like us to think about that given that
we've been sitting here and sort of
saying here are all these data sets that
we should use so maybe Chris I'll get
you to start most of you shouldn't use
them foreign
I think you you get to be driven by your
own interests
um but if those interests
um
coincide coincide with with the the
extremely broad set of data that's being
collected in each of these three surveys
it's worth taking a look and just
playing around with it um
yeah and so the
yeah even though your interests might
seem
very different from what people who have
used the data before have done that
doesn't mean it can't be used for what
you're interested in so just take a look
yeah
I would say in the The Case of the
Mexican family live survey it's a very
rich database it has more than
2 000 questions so basically I mean you
can there's lots of things and lots of
modules that have not been exploited so
you can exploit obviously the
longitudinal component and looking at
very very very different
um questions I I say you go and and dig
into the web page and I'm sure you'll
find a a question you're interested in
so um so while
you know rohini uh framed this as like
some tension between you know data first
or or research question first right then
I totally get that you know my
conversations with PhD students we also
emphasize the same thing but I I don't
think it always has to be a dichotomy
like that or it doesn't have to be
intention partly because I am just
continually Amazed by Young researchers
PhD students
um unbounded capacity for Innovation
right so you have data and as long as we
do the simple boring things of like okay
let's just make sure we ask all the
questions that seem relevant rather than
like thinking about what are the
interesting questions like people come
up and then they merge that data with
um like other policy changes or
something and we're amazed at the
outcome so for example after the the
collecting the cost with our panel
survey right so I was always trying to
think about okay how do I merge the
Bangladesh side with Myanmar side given
that it's impossible especially in that
particular state in Myanmar with the
rowing I used to live and and to collect
data but we were able to you know one of
our PhD students who was here now Jaya
Wen who's at Harvard Business School so
she knew about she works on conflict she
knew about the conflict
data and so we now merge those two and
have started uh thinking about how the
propensity for the Myanmar military to
engage in genocidal acts right buried
across different
um uh and what the what the trauma
effects were anyway so I'm I'm not
concerned that you'll find Fabulous
things to do I don't even know what they
are but yeah
we take some questions right there at
the back I think some of them might
report
uh hello thank you for uh the talk about
the panels oh sorry uh my name is Remy
Levin I'm uh at the University of
Connecticut I'm extremely happy that
you're talking about this because I've
used both the ifls and the mx4s and my
research and I think they're incredible
data sets one thing that I uh want to
ask you though is as far as these
longitudinal native sets one of the kind
of primary constraints is how persistent
they are over time right and so we've
now gone a decade without another wave
of the events fls and we're coming up on
seven or eight years without another
wave of the ifls and so I'm just
wondering if we're ever going to see
like new waves of these data sets
because you know at some point they
start getting stale and there's more
things I'd like to do with the data and
uh it would be great if we had more of
it you know
yeah that's my question
[Laughter]
well I feel exactly the same
we did collect like uh 50 of the data in
2018-19 we're actually trying to work on
um weights in order to to be able to use
at least that part
what we're doing
um as well is contacting these people
via phone
uh for the ones that we have phones so
that we can sort of keep contact with
them so in in the possibility that we
could collect another uh wave then it
would be easier because I mean tracking
people is is hard in Mexico especially
now given
obviously all the insecurity there is so
um
so keeping contact with them so they
don't forget about us it's crucial so
we're trying to do that and we're doing
everything we can to come up with the
funds to continue to study because we
believe it's it's a unique study and uh
especially from the family life service
the Mexican family that server has this
extra component of tracking individuals
to the US so it's it's really unique
can I get something yeah that's very
good there's a question down there
everybody can come down so much oh yeah
um so I'll just add that um your point
about the phone surveys it's that's
something that's become a really big
change in the way that all of us do
research right like the work from home
type uh region chain that happened
that's also happened with the way we're
serving things and it's a great way to
cheaply collect high frequency data and
also maintain contact with the panel of
hustle so that the in-person survey
where the finding rates increase
um I'd love to hear what
um you all think about doing more
individual level
stuff in those surveys the ability to
measure individual level poverty for
example within households it's very
important for all kinds of gender issues
of course
um I know there are trade-offs for
agriculture also very important looking
at individual level plots
um things like that just just wondering
what you all think about that
so I I think it depends on the context
and the question and so we're trying
we're striving to collect data at the
individual level where we can and it's
relevant so obviously
anthropometrics is at the individual
level businesses and farming and income
is at the individual level consumption
we don't even try
um just because it's
too much of a chance although we'd be
open to to adding a module to try to do
that in in some sub-sample for example
um
thank you so I wanted to ask a question
to mushrik about this very very
challenging survey among Refugee I was
particularly interested to know about
that if you you got special way to deal
with the challenge of tracking those
refugees and also what you mentioned is
that you keep these separate sample of 5
000 household or individuals which you
say are perhaps representative
but we know that when people are
escaping from violence they may not want
to be found they may not want to be
tracked so um what do you do with this
and thanks for your and your
collaboration which is very very
interesting
on uh yeah those are excellent questions
on the first question of you know how do
you track it's a particularly difficult
population absolutely right uh there's
no I mean there's no magical solution
that I can offer you can like how you're
imagining it's difficult it is actually
true it is it is difficult
um now the what we are doing is that we
actually spend some extra money some of
our budget in just making almost useless
from our from the perspective of
research phone calls right just to have
like touch points and conversations and
seeing whether they have new SIM cards
right
um like where they live now who else can
we contact so we're just the the only
thing we're trying to do is as long as
you maintain contact with them on a
regular basis right it becomes easier to
refine them right and the the other uh
the other point you made about like the
population really doesn't want to be
tracked
um we haven't in this population we
haven't found that to be a particularly
um
like a special challenge or anything
like that uh for whatever reason I mean
even though I mean they it's uh they
don't want to talk for more than two
hours but uh that's that's been a
problem for understandable reasons uh
but uh but like not not not particularly
that you know we're getting a lot of
like refusal to participate
um
I'm just wondering for
um that
um mxls and for the um
gsps if there's opportunities like the
ones that mushrik is um are is kind of
making available right so I mean I think
it's a it's a wonderful initiative you
have you spend all the money in the the
Baseline which is the most important the
most expensive part and then from there
people have asked like can people have
access to like all the sampling frames
to be able to locate like do you make
those things available to be able to
locate those households to do some other
studies
um or just that kind of like
de-identified data that it's publicly
available because I mean if those are
those opportunities are available I
think that would also make it
um very useful for researchers to kind
of do small things here and there using
those panels and then moving moving
those projects forward in particularly
in Mexico given the current
circumstances right
I might just jump in and ask that which
is the flip side which is not just the
IRB but also you know ethically um what
kind of how do you think about the taxes
you put on people when you enter them
into a sample in the long run
um you're looking at me
um
I'll hand off to Sam in just a second
um so the ethical issues are really
important
um it's it's clear that a determined
person
could identify a household in our on our
sample just from the data that even
though it's de-identified
um if you were to be a detective you
could go find them
um and
that's that's that's a problem
um and
uh that's also the main barrier to just
letting the
any researcher join in to do an
experiment or add a small module so what
our our practice has been to bring them
into our team
um go through the IRB at Northwestern
and and make an agreement with with the
pis that will do this jointly um or you
know
the added burden
what do you say to these have what what
how do households respond when we show
up for wave three yeah I think I'm um
you mentioned that thing which is once
we build a rapport with them it's pretty
much easy and we make or we work with
the same um interviewers so they know
them and they are familiar with them so
it's easier yeah getting them to
participate and on what you ask them the
opportunities are there but of course we
don't hand the sample to you you would
have to partner and then you won't know
where the households are but once you
give us the idea and what you want to do
we think through with you and then with
the uh experience and narrators they
give us feedback and then we communicate
so it's more like it works like that we
won't give the sample to you to go and
do what you want to do yeah I think in
the case of the MX fls would be the same
we have to take very good care of our
sample
right so we would be definitely open to
working uh with very different groups
but we would have uh to work together
we've done uh we've done experiments in
the past as well and it's worked very
well yeah
oh yeah
not out chipping I I think we currently
with the fourth wave of the Ghana panel
is ongoing and we have like some PhD
students collaborating with us and then
also some other I think
um UC Berkeley yeah yeah so we have some
other
um teams from UC Berkeley collaborating
with us on some studies so we are very
much open yeah I thank you talk to Chris
he will get you
so another dimension of the ethics
that's particularly
um that we have to be careful about
problematic for us is that we're talking
about a population that has recently
experienced severe trauma and um and
asking questions about trauma so
something we have to think carefully
about
um not that we I'm not saying we got it
right but I'll just tell you what what
challenges we had is that you know if
you
um if you make people relive their
trauma does that do longer term damage
right and so we had in place for example
if you're going to ask us a set of
questions that we will have
um you know uh support services
available should you need it later but
here's something I was surprised by that
and even Paola my co-pi who is uh who
normally works in like psychosocial
areas was surprised by that people were
really willing and wanted to share their
stories right so we had a so we had a
big qualitative component as well of the
survey not just collecting a set of vs
no or numeric responses where we like
wrote down sort of narratives of their
stories
thanks Shannon if you have any
connections to give us for the next
stage